[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dan wetzel is a columnist for yahoo
sports
and his latest column the headline is
does ohio state belong in the playoff
college football playoff committee has
painted itself into
a subjective corner dan wetzel joins us
now
why do you feel this way dan well
so it's kind of a nuanced column which i
know america loves nuance
uh at this point and uh especially
sports talk radio
uh it's a place for that type of debate
uh i don't disagree with the idea that
ohio state's one of the four best teams
and personally i would be
pretty excited to watch them play in the
playoff but there is a process
and i don't know how um
we went from a couple years ago where
we're keeping big 12 teams out because
they didn't play a
13th game they only played 12. it was a
big deal they only played 12 games and
others leagues got a
quote 13th data point was the big
bureaucratic term
ohio state has played five games that's
it
five games they'll play six four of
those games they'll have an off week
before it
um they you know they may be
one of the four best teams but don't you
have to play a season
to actually make the playoffs it's like
giving someone a chance at the masters
from the forward t's
uh you still gotta kinda you know you
finish the round but what exactly
happened so
it's a uh it's it's an interesting
debate because it goes completely
against
what they used to do now we know this
has basically always been a subjective
thing and they just reverse
engineer a reason on why they like this
team or that one but i don't know what
they're going to come up with on ohio
state other than
hey we just like ohio state because
you know when you're playing six games
and other teams are playing 12
11 10 and may have nine ten wins
uh it's uh you know you got to play i
mean we shouldn't reward it where the
easiest way to make the playoff is not
to play i mean it's a good way to avoid
losses
but at some point you have to play the
season let me give you full control
you got full control to decide who plays
in the playoff
so what would you do i'd expand the play
off but if i can't do that um
yeah i mean we'll see who wins this
weekend but
obviously if alabama wins alabama i
think should be in either way i think
notre dame should be in either way
uh barring you know 50 point destruction
at clemson i think clemson
is a team that you know they do have a
loss but if you're talking about
a loss a double overtime on the road
without your starting quarterback that
is a
i know it's a zero-sum game we play in
football but that is about as close of a
loss as you can possibly have
i think clemson still has the very good
argument i think if florida beats
alabama they still get in
florida at that point would have nine
sec victories which is the most of any
school to
ever play uh because normally you only
play eight regular season games in one
conference and they would have they
would have nine i don't think florida is
necessarily out of this if they beat
alabama
i would take a team like that because i
kind of just i
maybe i even even if i do love what ohio
state represents and how good they could
be
i'm kind of more of a process guy just
the way i think about it and i look at
and say
geez you know i mean i don't know how i
can take a team with nine wins
or a team of six wins over team with
nine or something like that
but obviously i think ohio state's got a
good point this really isn't a
a bash ohio state thing it's just the
big ten chose to do this
they chose to only play an abbreviated
season
late with no wiggle room you know the
fcc is going to get like 68 or 69 of the
71 scheduled games in
uh you could do this if you spread out
your season
the big ten chose to do this uh and so
they have a team that'll only have six
wins i i don't think you can just ignore
that
i was wondering about this last night
usc's 5-0
they got the pac-12 title game on friday
night against oregon they'll
if they win they'd be 6-0 if usc had a
recent resume
where they were one of the top five to
seven teams in college football
how would the committee look at usc if
they had this they haven't been
relevant here in a while but let's say
they have six wins they won the pac-12
and maybe they were up for a national
championship
uh time or two in the last five to seven
years would usc be knocking on the
doorstep of making the playoffs
my guess is yes and that's kind of the
issue you have with this is
and i get it this is a crazy year but
this is why it's completely subjective
what
what is it about let me put it this way
coastal carolina could go 12-0
okay coastal carolina has they could go
20 and oh dan
they could go 20 you know you're not
going to put them in yeah because you go
oh it's coastal carolina their recruits
aren't good enough we don't really
what is this uniform who where that what
carolina are we even coastaling
what is this right this is usc
us we know that uniform we know that
fight song and they have tons of great
recruits
they have tons of guys are going to go
the nfl their problem has been not
getting it organized and winning
so yeah agree like what is it about us
well they've been winning lately
or all of a sudden we're going to go
well some of these games are kind of
close
um how are they 15th they're currently
15
in the rankings right coastal like you
said they go 12-0 they're 13th they're
not even close
uh but but we go we move iowa state up
because they're in the big 12. well the
big 12 usually gets crushed in the
playoff like i don't think the sun belts
can do a whole lot worse the big 12 does
every year
uh it's it's it's all like it's not even
consistent
rank to rank and so you know at the end
of the day
especially in a season like this we end
up with like alabama playing
uh no notre dame and clemson playing
ohio state on new year's day
like set off the fireworks fantastic
this is gonna be awesome right
but if you care if you look at you dig
into this thing you go man this is just
i mean this is just ridiculous none of
this makes
any sense there's no consistency and
they're just sitting there going hey we
want these four teams and
we're gonna find a way to get these four
teams if they told me that up front dan
i would be fine with it
it's just they give you the impression
that dare to dream
but i likened it to you go through
the hazing part of trying to get into a
fraternity and then they don't let you
into the fraternity
and and and so i if you say look ohio
state
we love them that big fan base notre
dame big fan base clemson big fan base
trevor lawrence
and you got alabama nick saban and they
got pedigree okay i understand it
but don't tell me that uh well five
games that you you passed the site test
i think as you mentioned in your column
the titanic passed the site test
like this is silly when we go i don't
know if ohio state's great
because if you say based off what they
did in their biggest game against
indiana
i don't think they were great the big
ten was horrible this year
and now you've got northwestern coming
up it it doesn't mean that i don't want
to see ohio state it's just i don't know
how
one team earns it and another team
tries to earn it but they're not the
same they don't play by the same rules
absolutely and look again i don't think
coastal carolina is one of the four best
teams i don't really want to watch
alabama play coastal carolina
but if there was ever a year that a
school like that
should be at least in the discussion
it's this year because their league was
one of the only ones
to play non-conference games so you
could check and see how they were
and they beat all the big 12 teams
louisiana
who they're going to play in their
championship beat iowa state by 17
points
in ames and it's just like well we don't
care about that
coastal carolina beat by these are the
best games and so if you at the end of
the day said look
we have a process and hey you know covet
coastal carolina snuck in on a loophole
at least you go oh that's the process
instead we're just like there is no
process and we're you know we may get a
better playoff for it but
yeah stop with the two days of meetings
16 hours
and we have analytics and proprietary
data that you don't know about that's
what we're seeing
what data like you just want ohio state
in there that's fine just say it i want
ohio state in there this feels like
the usual suspects with kaiser sose
this committee is kaiser sose i don't
know who they are
and what they do but there's some stuff
that gets done there
and we'll never know what goes on behind
those closed doors there but
if i said you could do 18 playoff
16 playoff 12 six you know
16. i would do i would do eight i would
have five automatic bids for the major
five conferences which i think would
create
way more excitement around the country
and help
spread the wealth out a little bit right
now for the last five years no one's
cared about the pac-12
race you would actually care in a given
year if they're going to get in
um and what we need to do is create more
excitement for more schools so the
recruits spread out a little bit because
what we have right now is basically
about
four to five schools that can win a
national championship every year
uh you know it's alabama it's ohio state
it's lsu it's georgia it's clemson and
you know that's pretty much it actually
uh maybe notre dame can do it but
um and if you look at the recruiting
recruiting signing day is wednesday
guess who your top five are you know
there you go so it could
why not right if you're a kid you're
going i don't i want to play for the
title this is these are the only schools
to get in
so you want to spread it out i'd have
five automatic bids and then i have
three at large
you might create something where the the
group of six the lower schools if you
reach a certain benchmark
you can get in and bring kind of a
cinderella story in maybe gotta be
undefeated or you gotta rank certain
height but
um i think it would create a lot more
excitement you're just adding a game if
you look at all the stuff they used to
say well we can't
we can't do it because we can't play
games in december because of finals
uh i mean like rutgers and nebraska are
playing on friday afternoon
okay that's out the window you know the
the the sanctity of the rose bowl there
ain't gonna be a rose bowl this year
there's a good chance there's
no roosevelt they're just gonna move the
game you can totally do it you'll make
more money which y'all need
and you can you can set this up i just
think it'd be a much more exciting it'll
be better for the regular season and the
overall health of college football is
the one thing
it's a wonderful sport i love it but it
is the same suspects every single year
because unlike the nfl
the worst team doesn't get the best
draft pick the worst team gets the worst
draft pick
the best team gets the best draft pick
so it never ends
jim harbaugh seems to be safe at
michigan right
feels like uh seems if he wants to
return he will be able to return you
know the thinking in michigan
uh all along from ward manual is that
you know one bad year um
is one bad year brian kelly had a four
win season a couple years ago and
they're gonna make this
should make their second playoff
appearance in three uh marc d'antonio's
had bad years and michigan state come
back
it happens right with a great coach now
i don't know that jim harbaugh has done
what brian kelly has done at notre dame
but he certainly has earned that trust
within the michigan family yeah i
remember his dad was a long time coach
he's a ann arbor guy he played there for
beau
uh he you know has done a a
good job not he hasn't beaten ohio state
but it's really hard to beat ohio state
um but he's done a good a good job there
you're not having like a bunch of
arrests or problems with your thing or
anything like that they have a good
recruiting class so
there is a patience at michigan and
what's kind of funny
is in the world of college football that
patience is viewed as insanity
like what do you mean you're patient and
they're like look we still got like an
alum who's a super bowl winning coach
who
won nine games last year yeah it's not
that bad we'll give them one more season
it was cove and all that
people are like you're absolutely crazy
you're nuts and so
that's where we're at that's part of the
fun of college football too but yeah he
he'll be back and but next year you know
he
he has to he's got a very good
quarterback coming in out of the high
school ranks got this kid kade mcnamara
showed a little bit of promise before
getting hurt
he needs a quarterback desperately he
hasn't had a quarterback in ann arbor
it's been surprising
and that's been their their number one
problem and that's what's amazing
this is a guy who played quarterback at
a high level in the nfl
and he can't find a quarterback and it
feels like
there are so many quarterbacks when i
watch college football
usually what you lead with is who's the
quarterback and if you're successful
chances are it's because of your
quarterback and the fact that michigan
can't find one
and ohio state keeps churning out these
first-round draft picks
and they did it again this year with
justin fields i mean they just rub it in
make it even worse there for harbaugh
but
you'd think he'd have that ability to go
that guy
can lead my offense and he hasn't been
able to find that ohio state was so
stacked with quarterbacks they they
kicked joe burrow to the curb
i mean and this is what michigan used to
be
tom brady sat on the bench because you
couldn't get on the field i mean
michigan is a quarterback school
harbaugh didn't just play 14 seasons in
the nfl and not as a super talented
quarterback he
gutted his way through those 14 seasons
he also coached
andrew luck in college coached alex
smith that pros he went to a super bowl
with colin kaepernick
in a in an event of offense right so
it's not like while he was
he was peyton manning's coach it's like
well peyton manning's got his own coach
right
no he he developed guys and maxed guys
out the number one thing i thought
the last thing i thought would be a
problem with jim harbaugh going to
michigan was they wouldn't have any
quarterbacks i thought they'd have a ton
of them
until he gets one you can't win and he
hasn't had one and that's what's held
him back now does that change
we'll see uh but he will i think he will
be back for one more season unless some
nfl team comes in and says we
we want you and and there really isn't a
lot of buzz on that right now
dan good to talk to you as always and if
i don't talk to you uh
merry christmas happy holidays and uh we
appreciate your time
thank you mr patrick talk to you soon
dan whetsel yahoo sports columnist